good afternoon I'm professor Jung Jae
Joong I'm so happy to have a chance for
sharing a wonderful time with you I'd
like to introduce a why Korea need
special education a system for
conserving of cultural heritage ok Korea
has undergone with rapid development
during about 60 years and I have diverse
experience in conservation of cultural
heritage after korean whirl korea had
changed with the trace from undeveloped
country to newly developing country and
then become now korea yourself when
korea was undeveloped country the main
problem was economic issue in
conservation of cultural heritage
financial investment to work impossible
in conservation for cultural heritage II
and Korea cannot afford anything after
economy had have grown and technologic
has developed rapidly with the economic
policy of national level in this process
traditional materials and technique had
severed and this led the severance of
technical and export be lately even
though people tried to conserve the
cultural heritage there is no appreciate
conservation export of cultural heritage
also various academic field can taconic
are required to conserve world heritage
goguryeo tomb and muir paintings for
example what is the best technique for
conservation of cultural heritage
when conservation can make a progress
with the interdisciplinary a technique
and research cultural heritage can be
conserved probably with each own shape
and value but present reliably sometimes
appears differently differently how can
we specialize the education for
conservation of cultural heritage in
this context I want to introduce the
education system for Korean national
university of cultural heritage briefly
my university was established as on
affiliated organization of a cultural
heritage administration by government
for solving the problem in 2000 also
graduates glucose was set up as a reason
of training and fostering export a new
CH has multiplied the education system
with the cultural properties of
management ocurro's traditional
landscape architecture traditional
architecture traditional art and crafts
and conservation science we have as X
department particularly integrated the
professional as port and trained with
the interdisciplinary convergence
education a new CH can also participate
in the activity for policy determination
of a cultural heritage committee in GH a
and initiator will take a party in this
search and development activity with the
NRI CH also it can play a leading law
for conserving the cultural heritage in
the field sustainability from training
appreciate a sport appropriate export
conclusively it is expected that the
role of in university for education and
training of cultural heritage are to
emit specialists and is changed
professional technique in the period of
cultural heritage as a central zone for
into
preliminary and conversion expert thank
you for your attention